in countries across the continent
confidence in the astrazeneca vaccine is
ebbing away
even though the evidence linking it to
blood clots is flimsy
the netherlands has suspended the jab as
a precaution while european medicines
regulators
investigate the reports which include
some deaths
france italy and germany have also
joined around a dozen countries to pause
the rollout
today's decision is a purely
precautionary measure
millions of astrazeneca vaccinations
have been administered across the globe
all of us are very aware of the
consequences of this decision
and we did not take it lightly the
latest data from the european medicines
agency shows that out of 5
million astrazeneca vaccinations given
across the continent
there have been 30 reports of people
suffering a blood clot soon afterwards
but in a population of that size you
would expect 5 000 people a year to
develop blood clots
even without vaccination that's around
100 a week many more than the 30 who've
had clots after the jab
in the uk around 11 million people have
now had the astrazeneca vaccine
and the prime minister strongly endorsed
it we have one of the toughest and most
experienced
regulators in the world they see no
reason
at all to discontinue the vaccination
program
they believe that they are effective uh
highly effective in driving down not
just
uh hospitalization but but also serious
disease and mortality the world health
organization has urged countries not to
suspend the vaccine
because of the very real lethal risk of
covid that it prevents
uk experts are baffled by the european
action
we don't think there is any connection
however
you know safety is of paramount
importance and we will continue to
review this
data um on a daily basis the mhra
and and if there's any any problems at
all we would let the public know the
first
uh instance but we're not seeing any
problems with this vaccine that we're
worried about
the european regulator is due to give
its assessment of the vaccine safety
later this week
the confidence in the jab in some eu
countries was already shaky
after they held back at first from
giving it to the over 65s
and this new scare even if unfounded
won't have helped
thomas more sky news